[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de france 24 que los invita a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas seguimos enfocados en
la guerra de ucrania en los últimos días
los ataques rusos se han intensificado
golpeando objetivos tanto militares como
civiles en distintas ciudades del país a
pesar de los esfuerzos por una salida
negociada al conflicto el cerco sobre
quiebra capital se hace cada vez más
estrecho los rusos avanzan desde el
norte golpeando ciudades como butch a
oír ping pero también desde el sur donde
los bombardeos han alcanzado la
localidad de basil con tal y como lo
reportan los enviados especiales de
nuestras cadenas hermanas sino empañar
hijos e hijas
jeff decimos segundo día de ofensiva
rusa nos dirigimos al sur hacia las
zonas afectadas por los primeros
bombardeos básicos es una ciudad en
donde hay despliegues permanentes de
soldados un objetivo estratégico una
prioridad para las fuerzas rusas
estos son los efectos concretos de la
invasión militar de rusia en ucrania
estamos en la ciudad de basil kof a 40
kilómetros al sur de la capital
ucraniana y lo que ven en las imágenes
es una escuela que fue alcanzada por un
misil ruso una destrucción total de este
edificio además todavía hay a mis pies
libros escolares abrigos por lo que
podemos imaginar la fuerza del impacto
sobre este establecimiento
pienso en todos mis amigos que
estudiaron en este colegio
pienso en el viejo señor que trabajaba
aquí
es verdaderamente atroz para todas estas
personas y para los niños que estaban
aquí en el ayuntamiento de basil con los
voluntarios los soldados y las fuerzas
de defensa están activos las 24 horas
del día en los sótanos viven más de un
centenar de refugiados let me la era
profesora en la escuela bombardeada
ahora se ocupa de las familias
escondidas aquí
crees que tendrás que irte en algún
momento
no de ninguna manera nos quedamos esta
es nuestra ciudad y para ir adónde
y todos los que viven aquí han decidido
quedarse no vamos a huir lucharemos
tomaremos las decisiones correctas
siempre encontraremos una manera de
aguantar no tenemos ninguna duda
llevamos cuatro días sin salir
anoche estuvo bastante tranquilo está
bien
[Música]
la situación en esta ciudad refleja la
realidad ucraniana un implacable avance
ruso de una población decidida a
resistir
los hombres de entre 18 a 60 años están
obligados a quedarse en el país muchos
se unen a la guerra mientras que otros
terminan apoyando voluntariados o
manteniendo actividades económicas una
situación que obliga a muchas mujeres a
emigrar del país junto a sus hijos luego
de decenas de despedidas llenas de
tristeza e incertidumbre estas mujeres
se ven obligadas a cuidar de los menores
sin saber si algún día volverán a ver a
sus parejas padres o amigos informe de
catalina gómez ángel y oriola andrés
gaya
anaya alexander tendrán que posponer sus
planes por el momento la pareja se
comprometió hace unos pocos meses
ahora la situación en hardcore es más
difícil y no hay esperanza de que se
pueda solucionar
esta mañana ha venido a dejarla en la
estación fronteriza de choque desde
dónde van a cruzar a hungría junto con
una amiga de su madre
me siento terriblemente pero hay gente
que la está pasando mucho peor
las despedidas se repiten una y otra vez
en esta estación decenas de padres dicen
adiós a sus hijos y a sus mujeres en
sólo dos semanas la vida de más de 40
millones de ucranianos ha quedado en el
limbo esto es especialmente impactante
para los niños y jóvenes hoy llenos de
preguntas
irina es una de las cientos de miles de
madres que ha decidido sacar a sus hijas
del país
las tres temen por lo que le pueda pasar
al padre que trabaja en el este de
ucrania
esto es inesperado y me siento extraña
no sé no sé me siento mal quería seguir
en el colegio y seguir con la vida
tranquilo
para madres como irina lo más difícil es
cómo explicar a sus hijas esta guerra
que las ha alejado del mundo en el que
se sienten seguras en youtube vamos
chica pero les prohibimos mirar las
noticias hace sangradores años ellas ven
todo pero no sé cómo lo procesan y
ya en territorio seguro muchas madres
buscando quebrarse tienen que ocultar su
dolor aunque a veces es imposible este
es el caso de natalia que cirujana
hubiera quedado en ucrania para dar
apoyo pero antepuso la seguridad de sus
dos pequeños
ellos lo echan de menos pero el temor es
que no lo veamos más
la gran pregunta que se hacen es cuándo
podrían rehacer su vida pero sobre todo
cuando volverán a ver a sus padres
parejas y amigos
el conflicto armado comenzó el pasado 24
de febrero y desde entonces más de 3
millones de personas han huido de la
guerra se trata de la peor crisis de
refugiados desde la segunda guerra
mundial polonia es el país que más
refugiados ha recibido y el segundo país
de mayor acogida es hungría esta nación
que en el 2015 fue una de las que más se
opuso a la llegada de ciudadanos sirios
ahora cuando se trata de refugiados
ucranianos los ciudadanos se han volcado
a ayudar entre ellos hay ciudadanos
latinoamericanos que sienten la
necesidad de tender una mano a los que
llegan informe de catalina gómez ángel y
oriol andrés gallardo desde budapest
con cada tren que llega a este carril
humanitario de la estación kennedy deuda
pese una nueva familia que ayudar la
mayoría son mujeres con sus hijos todas
vienen aterradas por lo que han dejado
atrás y temerosas de lo que puedan
encontrar en esta nueva ciudad donde la
mayoría no conoce a nadie kate es una de
ellas huyó de aquí con su hijo leo de 5
años
solo empaque las cosas importantes
aquellas que no podemos reemplazar
dos días atrás fueron acogidos por una
pareja brasileña que como muchas
familias en budapest se han movilizado
para dar apoyo
venimos de brasil al otro lado del mundo
pero estamos aquí muy cerca de ucrania
así que todos tenemos que ayudar
30 bis a los suyos que se encuentra bien
su padre se ha alistado como voluntario
y su madre se negó a abandonar el país
el padre de leo dice que está más
tranquilo ahora porque su hijo está en
un lugar seguro
como ella cientos de mujeres van camino
hacia otros destinos hungría solo es un
lugar de paso
valentino yo dejar kif después de que la
ciudad fuera bombardeada estará el bazar
donde compraban comida nos cuenta
se dirige a estambul junto con su mismo
y tatiana a quien ha conocido en el
camino
de hecho yo estoy impresionada nunca me
imaginé ser acogida en polonia o hungría
de esta manera
saben que les espera un largo trayecto
pero siempre hay alguien dispuesto a
ayudar elianis es una de ellas en su
móvil guarda los rostros de las familias
que han acogido en su casa en estos días
ella entiende por lo que han pasado hace
unos años fue ella quien tuvo que
abandonar venezuela muchos llegan en
shock al principio porque han tenido que
salir corriendo literalmente
años atrás cuando millones decidió
subían de la guerra cubriendo una de las
caras oscuras de europa donde esta vez
el país se ha volcado a ayudar
desde el inicio de la guerra josé jesús
pacheco ha estado en primera línea de la
ayuda humanitaria desde la parroquia
donde trabaja junto a un seminarista
ucraniano y un párroco polaco este
hombre que desde hace más de nueve años
vive en ucrania pero que es originario
de carúpano una ciudad al noreste de
venezuela está brindando apoyo a
contrarreloj dando refugio a más de 1500
personas que han huido del conflicto
informe de ir en esa vida
a pesar de la guerra el venezolano jose
jesús pacheco decidió no huir y ayudar a
salvar vidas lo encontramos en la
parroquia juan pablo segundo en libia
última escala de decenas de desplazados
antes de escapar a otros países tuve la
oportunidad de haber estado el año
pasado en venezuela en un país que para
mí no era el que yo conocía hace 10 años
cuando salí de venezuela y una situación
mucho sufrimiento el sufrimiento del
inocente y creo que todo eso me preparó
para poder afrontar esto porque
mentalmente y físicamente muy agotador
12 horas escuchar porque mi labor más
que todo en el día es ayudar a las
personas ir a hablar con ellas un poco
no de intentar en medio de esta
oscuridad que es que ven que puedan
recibir esta buena noticia de que dios
nos ha olvidado de ellos de que dios
está presente ese sufrimiento y esto es
lo que yo intento intento llevarle con
mi presencia no como en la parroquia
refugio apenas hay hombres jóvenes la
mayoría son mujeres y niños
familia con el niño que hay ahora
a toda una familia todos son hermanitos
confieso que no pienso que como
latinoamericanos que somos más
sentimentales a mí se me hace más
difícil afrontar cada situación digamos
que
muchas veces los sentimientos juegan en
contra porque no como cuando estás
conmovido y quiere darle un mensaje de
consuelo a una persona y con tanto
sentimiento que es difícil en estas
habitaciones hay decenas de niños
mujeres que han encontrado aquí refugio
hay ropa que están donando las
asociaciones humanitarias que están
ayudando a estas personas en esta
parroquia que solía tener sólo tres
personas como habitantes ahora hay unas
aquí le preguntamos qué piensas qué
piensas de todo esto y muchos dicen que
lo único que puedo pensar ahorita es en
que vuelva la paz
cuando aún no es mediodía josé jesús se
despide de este grupo de desplazados que
van a ser evacuados en autobús su
destino en roma' el de josé jesús
asegura el seguir aquí con los más
vulnerables
el gobierno ruso ha pedido a sus
ciudadanos unirse en apoyo alrededor del
presidente vladimir putin y lo que él le
sigue calificando como una operación
militar especial sin embargo miles se
oponen a la guerra y terminan siendo
arrestados por expresar ese rechazo en
los medios de comunicación después de
una ley aprobada recientemente quienes
difundan lo que se ha considerado como
noticias falsas sobre las fuerzas
armadas se enfrentan a la posibilidad de
una pena de hasta 15 años de cárcel esto
ha llevado al éxodo de artistas
periodistas y activistas que se refugian
en lugares como turquía tal y como lo
reporta nuestra cadena hermana fondo
estambul se ha convertido en el nuevo
hogar de muchos rusos opuestos a la
guerra de vladimir putin en ucrania
incluyendo en el inah ella trabaja como
periodista independiente en moscú pero
decidió huir por su seguridad fama fue
una de las decisiones más difíciles que
he tomado tuve que tomarla rápidamente
no sabía por cuánto tiempo tendría que
irme así que hice una maleta cogí mi
cámara y me fui y viajo a una nueva ley
en rusia amenaza con hasta 15 años de
cárcel por difundir información falsa
sobre la invasión de ucrania muchos
periodistas del país se han dirigido
desde entonces a turquía
no somos traidores amamos a rusia y
queremos volver es nuestra casa no la de
putin
ni quinas sigue informando desde
estambul filmando a otros exiliados
rusos maya es una activista contra la
guerra y trabajo como directora de
teatro en san petersburgo donde su
pareja permanece atrapado
tengo mucho miedo por mi novio porque
puede ser realmente enviado al ejército
sabes
por ahora creo que está a salvo así que
podemos elegir la cárcel o el ejército
familias rusas enteras también han hecho
el viaje brad y maría que se oponen a
putin trabajan en la industria del cine
huyeron con su bebé y ahora se alojan
con un amigo
el limpiado mi computador porque también
estoy produciendo películas de
resistencia documentales contra el
régimen así que esos archivos tuve que
llevarlos conmigo tenía miedo
la familia continúa su resistencia en
estambul no a la guerra gloria ucraniano
a la guerra en rusia las protestas no
autorizadas están prohibidas
en rusia ahora no sería libre
físicamente no tendría ninguna
posibilidad de tener la mínima voz
con el espacio aéreo de la unión europea
cerrado a los aviones rusos es probable
que está un bulls sigue siendo un
destino clave para los rusos que buscan
escapar de la creciente represión del
kremlin contra la libertad de expresión
gracias por seguir esta nueva emisión de
corresponsales nos damos cita la próxima
semana siga con más información en
france 24 y france 24 puntocom